[Music]
prices So This is everything you need to
know That's new and Different this Year
These are the 10 new features of the
iPhone 7 number one is the new design
and you can see me As I set that but I
put new an air-conditioners because  like I said
This a very Family or iPhone to the Sex
and success Same Shape Same Dimension
Same Way Same Feel and the hand look
like an iPhone with some Saddle
unprovements like the enter bands on the
back Don't Go cross anymore so There is
a  cleaner look to the top in Bottom and
There's a new Said a Colors you have
your normal Silver your Classic Gold and
of course your Pink slash Rose Gold and
a number space gray Butt a Jet black and
Black so The Black Is this Oh Mad
blacklock and  I gotta say this feels
really good and Looks Good In Person and
the Jet Black is a piano superglasty
finish that I don't think I can
seriously recommend anyone you Looks
Good Wally Keeping Which is what There
we're doing here not Only is a probably
going  to  be the slipperie is iPhone
about time but it was so gonna be super
Pronto fingerprints like Samson phones
and scratches This one i picked up in
the demo Area some How already had micro
scratches on it so Apple Nose of the
issue and Just recommend use case What  I
think it Lame So I'm In be grabbing that
Mad Black something about the stuff Look
Just Speaks To Me number two The Home
button ben nu home button on the iPhone
7S actually really Simulator 2 Force
Touch track pads in the new macbooks It
Doesn  't actually click anymore It A
Solid Stay Glass button with pressure
sensitivity that doesn't move so There's a
tablet engine That's Now behind the
button So You formally present as If You
Were Going Home eclicks and I can a feel
like the whole bottomedar phone is
clicking  so not dennical to the Field of
Just a Bottom press from Before so May
Take some Getting used to but that is
definally new number 3 we iPhone 7 and 7
Plus are now officially water and
dusresystem now  I am I are you that the
iPhone 6s and even A6 My of ben Justice
water system as Us One But Now the
Officially Visual so It's a rated to be
able survived Being under 15 meters of
water Which is a lot So You Can talle
Use In  The Rain or Shower With It or
Whatever Number Four is the new camera
or cameras on the back the iPhone 7 has
a new 12 make a pixel camera with
f1.iture up to call image table Asian on
Both phones 7 and 7 Plus and i have  wel
again things like the New Image
processing ship quo Art LED Flash and
raw image capture Which is awesome And
The Beautiful new Big camera bump on the
back to the phone There is also a new
Seven megapixel front Face And camera
that actually Looks a lot better  than
previous iPhone This Is Real upgrade and
after parment so That's Never Thing The
re upgrade is in the bigger phone The
iPhones 7 Plus Which has two of these
new 12 megapixel cameras but Different
lenses and from each So on the right Is
The Normal 28 mm  lens sanos  a smaller
phone and on the left is a 50-6 mm lens
so Twice that focal distance for
basically's Optical Zoom So This 2x
camera is better for portraits and for
subject further Way Send That's What
telephone good for and the camerasa of
War this also know  a button to The
Switch activelly Between The lenses so
One X do for the normalands and two x
with the telephone
a slider sort of Wheel The Let You see
smoothie Us Digital to transition
between Them with expecting an update to
the software for the Seven plus That  Way
a cameramode called portrid that Like A
solliard to the background of the Human
subjects so Last Of interesting Stuff in
the camera that I'm hoping Works as well
Us A seems to know that all be hit in there
hard in the for review of this phone
number five that display so the i
Before Same size Same resolution Same I
PS takeology but it's a parently up to
25% Rider and Has A Whiter cover gambit
so Colors Wall popular
probinar Quiet like an Oled Never six  is
the stereo speakers and I wanna put that
in Eric quotes again to so It's A Little
Bit of anarch the dark setup Is You can
see the Bottom of the phone is Won't a
speaker Girls It's down under facing And
that Top of the phone  actually in the
airpiece He's The Other Side Of The
stereo Pair and That's front facing So
You At The weird but technically that
makes the stereo speakers no Idea How
Good They Sound Year Got A testay When I
Get It number 7 Lighting Year pods Every
iPhones 7  and 7 Plus was ship with These
Lightning Here but because There's No
headphone jack the new iPhone Ja I know
we start coming but it's Stocking weird
actually seed happen yeah Apple would
join Motorola in Shipping Every phone
with adapter this Ones a little Lighting
to audio jacketapter  that was so RET
for 9 dollars Which is get to know
because your problem a lose it and
speaking of Things you're gonna Lose
number 8 is Apples and Traduction of
optional wireless earpods The collum
ai  rpods
I Get It is Will Be 160 dollars and
There Pretty muchick Zack The would they
look like it's earpods Without The
cables he can look like a sideboard
wearing on but it earpods that Years
Dennis Wall to halfally wellness Enough
foreig what you Walk arr Run I  will see
that Price Tag there a Tough Sell but
People here seem to really like him They
demo would how the paradome super Easily
this Weekly They Common as Little
charging barricase and a charges them
and I have to do two Connect is Philip
Open A Top of  the case and When You put
the main your ears It uses Park symmety
sensors to automatically no There Being
listen to so switches your own offly
There is also a Touch sensitive Back So
you can Double Tap to activate serie and
Talk to her With The Bold And
microphones soy It's It's More Than
Just earpod Without The wires yeah 160
bugs Here Call an at one number Was A
Miner One a small update to Apple Pay to
work in Japan and last but not least
number 10 is  the news specs The iphon 7
has a new athen Fusion chip Inside Which
Is A few benefits Better Performance
with the CPU and Better GP Performance
Wall For Better gaming and it's a quad
Court ship with two adose course Being
lower Power so in Theory It's a More
efficientship that should Give You and
extra hour to a battery life orally
iPhone 6s and success plus in Theory a
legually I'm either Way That's prima
[ __ ] for what new and my persons are
that wallet's Pretty familiar eh yes that
nice piece of hardware They kill  the 16
gigabyte version finally so Now It
starts at 32 GB and the same Price and
it goes up to the fifty six Gate version
my favorite upgrade I Wanna Say Us
probably The camera as person in the 7
Plus Which was The Phone House Gonna Get
Anyway  and my biggest let Down I Would
say is the screen When I Thinking The
put and over
Thank you for watching this Only Look at
the new phones definition share this video
with anyone Who would 1 know What's Good
wi  th Apples new phones and you should
you subscribe if you have an Our Ready
to be a mong the first The see the for
review When not Comes Out Long with much
More tack in between Thank you for
watching and not hot to gets an Next One
thes
[Music]